[Musique]
bonjour hélène bonjour pauline ont parlé
dans le journal à la une ce matin la
menace de la turquie de bloquer
l'adhésion de la suède et de la fal de
la finlande à l'automne notre seule
attente vis-à-vis de nos alliés de
l'otan et qu'il fasse preuve de
solidarité envers la turquie pour
protéger ses frontières et renforcer sa
sécurité a justifié recep tayyip erdogan
le président turc cité par hürriyet
entend peser on l'entend de tout son
poids dans les discussions sur l'entrée
et deux pays nordique dont l'adhésion
requiert l'unanimité des 30 pays de
l'otan dont la turquie est membre depuis
1952 d'elie saab a justifié la position
dans les cheptels perdon par le soutien
de la finlande et de la suède aux kurdes
du pkk et à la confrérie gülen qui est
accusée on le sait par le président turc
d'être derrière la tentative de coup
d'état de 2016 mais aussi en raison des
pressions que les deux pays scandinaves
ont exercé auprès de l'union européenne
pour un peser un homme un embargo sur
les livraisons d'armes à ankara après
l'intervention turque en syrie le
journal suisse le temps évoque lui une
tentative de la part du président turc
pour marchander son soutien y compris
auprès des états unis qui refuse de lui
livrer des avions f-35 à cause de la
décision de la turquie d'acheter des
missiles de fabrication russe
la presse européenne qui s'inquiète de
l'envolée des prix et de ses
répercussions sur le pouvoir d'achat
plus 4,8 % d'inflation en moyenne sur un
an en france le parisien relèvent que
cette hausse des prix n'a pas le même
impact pour tous les français les plus
touchés étant les classes moyennes les
habitants des zones rurales et les plus
âgés au royaume uni où l'inflation a
bondi de 9% sur un an
le chef de la police prévient dans the
guardian que cette hausse spectaculaire
du coût de la vie risquent d'être
associée à une augmentation de la
criminalité et recommande à ses agents
de faire preuve de discernement je le
cite lorsqu'ils seront amenés à
poursuivre des individus réduit à voler
pour pouvoir se nourrir se défendant de
demandé l'amnistié pour les personnes
ayant commis des crimes dits de pauvreté
ou de vouloir donner carte blanche aux
auteurs de vol à l étalage ndi cook
conseil ces policiers d'appliquer la loi
de la meilleure façon possible je le
cite toujours en attendant les critiques
s'accumulent face à l'action jugée
insuffisante du gouvernement pour lutter
contre la hausse des prix et c'est à
voir pauline avec un dessin de peter
brook pour the times qui montre boris
johnson s'alarmant de ce que 9% c'est
vraiment trop proche de 10 10 comme bien
sûr le 10 downing street la résidence du
premier ministre britannique
à la une également l'annoncé hier de la
fédération de football des états unis
qui a trouvé un accord pour assurer
l'égalité des primes entre les équipes
nationales féminines et masculines le
wall stret de nouvelles parlent d'un
accord en effet historique conclu après
des années de pressions juridiques sur
la fédération de football américaine un
combat qui a été mené par les membres de
son équipe féminine quadruples 1
championne du monde et notamment par la
star la chevelure coloré megan rapinoe
il a fallu une révolution mais l'équipe
de football féminine des etats unis a eu
ce qu'elle mérite salue le washington
post l'argent c'est le respect pendant
trop longtemps les footballeuses
américaines ont reçu une peine leur
signifiant qu'elles étaient des
marchandises à bas prix et que leur
médaille d'or était bon marché écrit le
journal les membres de l'équipe
nationale féminine des etats unis seront
enfin apprécier comme les trésors
nationaux qu'elles sont se réjouit le
quotidien qui estime pauline que la
partie la plus radicale de ces nouveaux
contrats établis par la fédération de
foot américaine n'est peut-être pas
cette question des salaires mais sa
clause qui porte sur la garde des
enfants pour les équipes féminines mais
aussi pour les équipes masculines
le contrat est chouette mais c'est son
principe à savoir l'égalité qui est sans
doute la vraie libération se réjouit le
journal
on salue en effet cette décision merci
beaucoup hélène c'était la revue de
presse